it's so when you're talking about mental
health especially right now i think
we're all
like everyone on the planet is and
playing some kind of mental game
you know at some point just because it's
you're so i say your world is completely
changed from your daily routine
and your kids or you know if you have
kids in your house that's a whole other
thing and they and those poor little
dudes they're all like
they're they're just running and going
what's happening my mom my little
six-year-old is like is there sickness
still happening and i'm like no
yeah you know for a minute when
quarantine had first started i was
hiding my emotions from my kids because
i didn't want them
to see mom kind of like yeah you know
all over the place i always say that i'm
kind of like bipolar right one minute
i'm like yeah i got this and then the
next minute i'm like no
i don't got this but i found that
holding it in
i think that's called being human and a
mom but
thank you girl um but yeah but i found
out that
when i was just holding it in i remember
i had meditated for the first time
during quarantine which had been a while
i was just like focusing on everybody
else and not myself you know what i mean
and moms to do that a lot and i just
started
crying like everything just started to
just
you know let go and and release and it
was very it was very healthy for me so
my point in sharing that story is
you know during this time if anybody you
know wants some advice
especially when it comes to your mental
health number one know that you are
worth it
you know what i mean know that you are
worth taking that time out to give
yourself some sort of self-care
and that's exactly what you know i did
and it and it really
helped me and it's helping me during
this whole this whole
crazy situation that we're in right now
is just
taking time out you know for yourself
and i think i think you're
i think moms especially just but in my
experience with
moms and dads i know it's it's more than
moms are always
we we are so worried about everybody
else's
stuff like their mental health how
they're doing checking in with them
making sure their needs are being met
and you we are the last ones
that we look at and that is so
destructive not just for you but your
family as well
that's a great perspective subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going